il aura fallu seize ans pour parvenir à
cette signature signature qui permettra
à un projet d'urbanisme de changer la
face du quartier chantier à versailles
un dispositif important pour lequel le
maire de versailles françois de mazières
s'est battu je crois qu'on peut être
très content parce que ça un projet qui
remonte à plusieurs années
on a tous beaucoup travaillé dessus je
pense y correspond bien à ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui pour 21e siècle
c'est un projet qui intègre la dimension
environnementale
l'ancien projet est un projet construit
sur dalle de béton et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les gens demandent un
équilibre entre le construit la nature
c'est ça qu'on a essayé de faire et
c'est un projet très intéressant parce
que il intègre plusieurs dimensions la
vie des résidences seniors des bureaux
et des logements sont à prévoir au total
quarante cinq mille mètres carrés le
tout dessiné par deux architectes de
renom elisabeth et christian portzamparc
ça va ressembler un projet comme
versailles en connaît peu et un projet
contemporain
un projet ouvert un projet avec une
forte présence d'un espace public
végétal arboré avec des bâtiments qui
rayonne sur l'extérieur et des bâtiments
qui mélangent leurs fonctions un grand
mélange des gens est une énergie qui
n'est pas forcément celle que versailles
que nos quotidiens dans dans une
architecture très belle mais qui date du
viiie siècle
le nouveau projet d'urbanisme du
quartier de versailles chantiers sortira
de terre en 2019